self-awareness so this is the one that
i'm passionate about like for me so much
has worked for me because i understand
myself in space strengths weaknesses
yeah and also when you deploy empathy
with self-awareness by the way being
gary vee is all based on this like i'm
aware why somebody be like [ __ ] this
dude i'm empathetic to that i get all of
it it makes it palpable here's actually
talk about something that's powerful
my greatest
fear was to create fear in my companies
i hate fear you don't want a culture of
fear in the business and that's what i
think everybody does yeah
and i didn't want to rule by fear
because i know it's not how did paranoid
survive and my dad ruled by fear so i
became very visceral to it um
when i had to wake up four or five years
ago
and finally the subconscious became the
conscious
and i realized that my lack of candor
actually was creating a ton of fear at
vayner media
because people didn't know where they
stood and you would have you're telling
people what they wanted to hear you're
you're
avoiding things that's right
no i think i was massaging i was trying
to coach it through in a different way
i would i didn't care about money so it
creates politics right because people
are like we're not getting the truth we
got to do this correct side act correct
and more importantly pandering to me
because i'm the ruler right and so
when i really had that that was a really
dark moment for me in my career because
when you realize the thing you most
didn't want to do was happening
and so then i had to market to myself
i was like candor doesn't work for me
and literally chipped away at it and
when the word kind went in front of it
it's been wild and by the way the last
18 24 months where my game has gone from
a 10 out of 100 to call it maybe i'm a
60 out of 100 right now
that 50
has been monumental in my business
success interesting and so that
motivated me to say [ __ ]
i can't believe how much of an impact
this is having because i had a lot of
things going for me but man just this
one
what happens if i actually get people to
truly just deploy accountability because
everybody that is listening right now
has worked with somebody who just blames
people for everything it just is with
the way it is and like if you make that
change everybody around you
will adjust very quickly right right um
patience
i've come to learn
was so easy for me and is like
impossible for everybody mainly this is
how i got down the path mainly because i
didn't realize how many people valued
other people's opinions so of course you
want to be successful at 25 you want to
show your mom you want to show your
friends you want to show the world of
course you're lacking patience you want
a bmw you want a rolex you want a blue
check mark you want a million followers
you want to be an entrepreneur and all
this bad behavior happened in the last
decade because of it well i think it's
important to point out how they
interrelate with each other because this
is so when people hear accountability or
humility or candor in isolation they're
okay but you can they can also turn into
problems right so for the stoics when
we're talking courage temperance justice
wisdom courage for an unjust cause or a
stupid cause right doesn't work patience
for something that isn't working if
you're not holding yourself accountable
to the patients or you're you're not
being empathetic they all interrelate
can i ask you a question what about this
one because this one is
i number two attitude no gratitude
myself
yes gratitude is number one on this list
and back for a reason yeah every day's
good
of course you're alive you're alive
nobody died
you're a black swan of black swans we
should not exist 800 that's right 400
trillion to one yeah 850 million people
on earth do not have access to clean
water the [ __ ] am i upset about this
meeting getting cancelled
and and how how much would you have
killed to be in the position you were
in right now taking for granted right
like we would be the stoics talk about
how if we lost what we have we would be
devastated and if we saw someone else
with what we have
five years earlier we'd be insanely
jealous of them and then we sit around
going like i'm being unhappy with what
we have it's insane yeah so no but
number seven yeah self-awareness so this
is the one
that i'm passionate about like for me so
much has worked for me because i
understand myself in space
strengths weaknesses yeah and also when
you deploy empathy with self-awareness
by the way being gary v
is all based on this like i'm aware why
somebody be like [ __ ] this dude i'm
empathetic to that i get all of it it
makes it palpable
to me this is why ego is so dangerous
right you can't make stuff for other
people whether it's art or products like
when you think about kanye west or steve
jobs we think of them as egotistical
people not at all they couldn't have
been while they were making incredibly
not true because it was rooted not just
in empathy for other people but an
understanding of what where a hundred
percent they're reverse engineering the
consumer yeah has to be they may be
audacious they may be aggressive they
may be
they listen i do it they may enjoy the
communication of what they're up to in
your face but muhammad ali and babe ruth
did the same thing and people were mad
at them
until they weren't right
like like it's not super complicated
like if you're good enough to call your
shots
so how do you cultivate self-awareness
then that's the that's the paradox well
what's funny about this book and i
appreciate you reading it you saw i
actually took a real stab at it like i
really sat there and said okay great i
can put these 13 things down and what
enjoy yourself right so i did these
exercises
i i really tried to create this thing
that i've replicate because it's been
asked of me a lot through the years and
the game i won with some people more
inner circle occasional fans is sit down
three to four people that are closest to
you in the world have a kumbaya for two
hours and eliminate all fear from them
on giving you the truth and then create
an anonymous structure for them to tell
you your strengths and weaknesses and
then whatever like
once you start playing with that
whatever is uh
resonating or not resonating you start
double clicking into right you start
challenging yourself to be uncomfortable
like like to me can i actually i'm gonna
go very vulnerable here
the candor thing happened very simply i
went in
saw an interaction between two former
employees on some social network
and they didn't like me
and i loved them
and i
went to bat for them for a long time and
i entitled them
i over coddled them because i wasn't
able to give them feedback
and then i got to my wit's end and i
fired them and i'm the bad guy and i sat
there and i said i am a man
who
long ago
became fulfilled financially
[ __ ]
a hundred thousand dollars that was it
it all changed after that
not another time in my life has anything
felt like anything was all extra from
there all extra from that little of a
number okay very nice it's incredibly
nice that's why i've been so happy
i'm a man that's not motivated by that i
care about how many people show up to my
funeral i've got all these things going
on i'm talking all these things and why
are these two wonderful people who had
plenty of love for me at one point why
are they sitting here having a combo
[ __ ] on me
i'm like it's i'm doing i i pushed
myself further
i'm like i've got a flaw and i'm gonna
[ __ ] fix it and i knew what it was
but i didn't couldn't like get it to you
you know you can't get it to your
[ __ ] tongue i'm like it's [ __ ]
candor
and [ __ ] and then i started going down
why do i hate it so much and i go into
my mom doesn't have it she's my hero she
raised me then i looked my dad has it
but the way he delivered it was so
negative
everybody hated my dad that worked for
him you over accomplished
overcompensated
like i've come to learn that when
something's over here you want to go in
the middle not over like but i would i
[ __ ] went that's what temperance is
the the perfect respect so i didn't have
the right temperance on it and it became
my half
and i'm excited to talk about it and
it's so crazy because it is my strength
as a public figure
i love you no [ __ ] like it's like
it's all i get and it's cause the
context of the setting speaking into the
ether piece of cake
speaking to sally who i know like has a
sick kid
[ __ ] me
right if the over empathy and over
comp you know compassion and the over
sympathy which are nice things i went
too far i couldn't find my temperance
you know
no that makes sense i'm in this writer's
group like james clear mark manson we
get together once a year we sit around
and everyone gets to talk we all take
turns you get to talk about the person
as if they're not in the room and they
can't say anything all they can do is
take notes and it's super powerful
because you get to see how people you
actually care about not just random
people on the internet or whatever
you and you feel like everyone's caught
good candor yeah yeah and and but
because they are in the room you're
still going to be kind right and so and
you can't go all the way there right but
you can you can plant the seed of what
they can take back and go you know what
they're right i am doing too much of
this or not enough of this or why am i
being held back here and then you take
that back and you work on it you it's
ironic because we're talking about
self-awareness but one of the best ways
to get it is from other people i would
say a spouse being the primary way
because they know you better than anyone
and uh they can also
speak to you the most directly i think
that it is just a big goddamn deal and
all of this is and it's really time that
we actually talk about it as
like like the alternate title to this is
the soft skills are hard ooh that'd be a
good title thank you you know and so
that to me is what um right because it's
double cut right oh [ __ ] anyway i uh i'm
just
ready for this cause i know it
to be true
i know it to be true of course you can
build an empire by not being nice
a lot of them are that way of course but
if you're on the other side of reading
it wouldn't it be nice to enjoy it like
have you met the 70 year old titans that
did it the other way no they're disliked
that person's [ __ ] life blows like i
love that you put these people on a
pedestal they're not happy they're not
as happy as you think like
for real yeah no no it's uh
you would if you actually knew what it
was like in their head you would not
trade places with them for all the money
in the world it's why i always get crazy
about that i'd rather cry in my ferrari
than but like
how about not crying
yeah how about smiling in your [ __ ]
whatever yeah forward well you're
jealous of this person who's traveling
on a private jet to some exotic but what
if you had a life that you didn't need
to run away from
right like like what are we talking
about
like
yeah
all right a couple more quick riffs mark
surrealist says uh
strict with yourself tolerant with
others
how do you like that
a lot yeah yes i would actually argue
that that's where i need to find a
little bit of balance my strictness with
me is such a healthy one and my
tolerance with others may be too extreme
back to lack of candor i'm trying to get
a little bit better coddling entitlement
um but my strictness with me is really
cool uh it's not like i eat a five or
wake up it's
it's this ability to
not compromise on a couple of things
and the biggest one is kindness
yeah or it's like if you're driven and
ambitious you work 15 hours a day it can
be really easy to just expect that from
other people one of my favorite videos
you're talking to someone they're like
you're like the other people they're not
owners of the business you can't expect
what you expect of yourself of them it's
absurd i i once said to somebody i'm
like you're talking as if we're talking
about slavery yeah what the [ __ ] are you
talking about um yeah my i have zero
expectations of others if i'm being
really
honest i take that well you're always
pleasantly surprised yeah like and i'm
accountable it's like look i mean
yeah i
i love that and i'm a believer of it
yeah and look it's called
self-discipline
right not not
you know nothing else this is a lot
about why people
point fingers why people have fallen in
love with judgment of others and i've
come to realize it's because they're
practicing on themselves
you know my inability to over judge
myself
is exactly why i don't judge others
we're we're holding ourselves up to
we're the judge and jury and we're
putting ourselves into jails
right right like it's nice to have asper
i mean i'm ambitious as [ __ ] sure it's
nice to have standards i'm not saying
that but like this notion of beating
yourself up when you fall short on
something that is a standard or ambition
is incredibly unhealthy
well it's like you would never talk to
someone else the way that you talk to
yourself
but what's funny is mine is actually
slightly twisted on that i talk to
everybody the way i talk to myself which
is why i talk so nicely to everybody but
that's how you want it right but most a
lot of people
talk to themselves in a way that they
would never tolerate correct because
most people try to prop themselves up by
tearing everybody else down right
all right so mark's realize again uh the
best revenge the best way to get even is
to not be like them
my
i think there's something i like that uh
my version on revenge is a little bit
more like
the inability to even care about their
action
to shrug it off in in a more audacious
way
not only shrug it off
recognize that you're about to actually
stick it to them
by not even acknowledging it happened
it's it's an extreme version of cutting
them out of your ecosystem sure
that's how i've dealt with like people
that have done really not nice things or
trying to go like it's almost as if it
didn't happen yes it like goes on this
nice little shelf i'm like that's nice
you can play with yourself in that
cocoon of like whatever you feel about
me you've now become
a
energy that is just like
not a good use of time
and even giving it time and to be frank
i've evolved a little bit from that
i'm now
receiving that energy and kind of
deploying really deep sympathy the
thought at this point in my life that
you want to spend any of your time
hurting somebody else's feelings seems
outrageously foreign and really just
makes me feel compassionate
the ultimate person who suffers from it
is them a hundred all that we're doing
out here
is ex somebody said something to me
yesterday i did something kind of cool
giving away some stuff and
and they were like kind of asking i was
like late i was getting home i was just
replying like
it's just because i have so much love to
give i don't know what to do with it all
that's sweet and i really think that
that's that a lot of people live the
reverse they have so much pain they're
trying to get it out
you know for me it's an abundance of
love i'm like [ __ ] it like i don't wanna
like what am i like this is like i
better do stuff
um
i think that's how hate works
[Music]